general assembly and signed by a
republican stay in tax so ladies and
gentlemen let me introduce to you our
three great candidates for Ohio Supreme
Court Justice Pat Fisher Justice
[Applause]
[Music]
real easy
have one of these and if I hear tired of
inflation
right I give you four for the price of
three if you vote for free and all three
win we get four on the court and we take
back conservative control over the
course
don't forget that's Fisher with a c for
the Constitution and Common Sense thanks
good morning
what happens over the next four days is
going to decide the direction of the
Ohio Supreme Court whether we have Ohio
Supreme Court it does what's supposed to
that is apply to losses written protect
the Constitutional freedoms and not
legislate From the Bench or we go in the
other direction have an activist Ohio
Supreme Court
if anyone wants to see the danger of an
activist Court they just need look at
the debose decision this is a case where
a majority on the Ohio Supreme Court
said that judges cannot consider Public
Safety when they set bail for violent
criminals the three of us wrote the
sense in that in that case and issue one
is going to overrule the decision by the
majority
[Music]
but the reality is we cannot afford to
have to amend the Constitution every
time the Ohio Supreme Court decides the
case that's why it's critical that the
three of us win this race and we go back
to having a conservative Ohio Supreme
Court thank you all very much
foreign
beliefs We Believe judges say what the
law says not what the law should be
we believe that judicial decisions
should be based on the text of the
Constitution as understood when it was
written and that political views and
personal opinions and outcome do not
drive our decision-making process and
that is what is on the line in the next
four days there's always one more thing
that you can do as you keep your head
down and you run through the tape I
encourage you to ask your family and
friends to vote for the Constitutional
conservatives the Law and Order
candidates for the Ohio Supreme Court
and with your help we will hold the Ohio
Supreme Court and maintain it in
constitutional hands go fight and win
Ohio thank you
great candidates make a job a lot easier
for a state party chairman
nothing could be more true than that
it's uh it's also my pleasure to
introduce our uh Treasurer State and
candidate for re-election my good friend
Robert
[Applause]
um
I'll tell you I was coming up from
Philly I thought you know all this Vlog
this is kind of like Joe Biden's
thinking
you know and I thought like this is why
we have all these policies uh they're
like oh we don't know what's causing the
inflation it's a worldwide phenomenon oh
wait a second you spent eight trillion
dollars since the beginning of your
Administration ladies and gentlemen just
to let you know how much eight trillion
dollars is it took our country from the
Inception in 1776 until the Year 2007
for us to accumulate an entire national
debt of of eight trillion dollars and
that's what they spent in the last two
years that's why we have inflation here
in the state of Ohio today
uh have you felt it in your personal
budget yes
my wife has this peculiar condition uh
she actually believes that when the gas
light comes on in the Suburban it gets
better gas mileage does anybody else
have this problem uh and so I went to
fill out the the Suburban this summer
when the gas light was on and
unbelievable 105 dollars to fill up our
family car all right that's what
Americans are facing that's what Ohioans
are facing and that's where our farmers
are facing here in the state of Ohio and
we heard from one farm he said look the
cost of the Harvest for me has gone from
thirty thousand dollars to seventy
thousand dollars this year
Now farmers have always been the
backbone of Ohio's economy and we have a
28 billion dollar balance sheet in the
treasurer's office so one of the things
we did this last year along with the
general assembly and the governor was we
created a brand new program we modified
our AG link program and we released all
of all of the Caps off the aglink
program so that now they can get up to a
half a million dollars for a planting
loan and we can lower their interest
rate anywhere from a half percent up to
three percent it's a way that our
balance sheet can stand with Ohio
Farmers because they are the backbone of
Ohio's economy
foreign
thinking there's nothing we can do about
inflation really here at the state level
but we could do something about the
direction of our country on November the
8th on November the 8th if we show up
and we get out our vote we are going to
take back the United States House of
Representatives we are going to take
back the United States Senate we are
going to set this country in the right
direction
now I'll tell you I make sure that your
taxpayer dollars are safe but we have a
Green Beret that's making sure that our
elections are safe here in the state of
Ohio and I want to introduce them now
please welcome thankfulness
foreign
hey good morning everybody
so you guys know my mission you know
what I'm responsible for it's making
sure that we keep our elections honest I
think that's pretty important don't you
agree all right good so we do things
that somehow drive to the left nuts like
removing dead people from the voter
rules we do that every month and all of
Ohio's 88 County Boards of elections of
course everything we do in elections
actually bipartisan it takes Republicans
and Democrats to run the process I have
ordered our boards of Elections to audit
every election that's when we count the
hard copy paper and compare it to the
electronic result and we give you the
results on Election night isn't that a
novel idea
yes just this week the state of
Pennsylvania started telling people you
know we're probably not going to be able
to give you results on Election Day
folks that's not how we do it here in
Ohio the boards of Elections know and
the team at the Secretary of State's
office know a real pot of coffee
nobody's going to bed until we get those
unofficial results out there so that
everybody could know
Ohio has really emerged as the gold
standard around the country for how
elections should be run and it's a
simple thing we believe that the voice
of the people should be heard in a free
and fair election that's exactly what we
do and by the way when Ohioans show up
in massive numbers Republicans do really
well the left has this theory that
Republicans want to try to suppress the
vote it's an absolutely foolish idea it
is demonstrably false if that's my
objective I must be really bad at it
because we've had record turnout in 2016
2018 and 2020 and we're going to have a
strong turnout in 2022 and Republicans
are going to sweep the state of Ohio
because we have the policies
I am the only secretary of state in the
nation to earn the endorsement of
President Trump and that's something
else I'm very proud to have and that's
something that really is going to make a
difference listen guys in Ohio we make
it easy to vote and so here's my message
for us as we as I wrap up make sure to
tell your friends to get out about I
know all of you are voters we need to
get the others out to vote we make it
really easy in Ohio early voting
continues this weekend we've got evening
hours and weekend hours Most states
don't have anything close to that goes
through through Monday in Ohio you still
have time to get that FC ballot mailed
in it's probably too late to request it
although the law says you can wait till
Saturday that's a bad idea if you have
an empty ballot you want to get it in
and then of course there's election day
from 6 30 a.m till 7 30 p.m listen
complacency is dangerous we've been
hearing for a long time there's going to
be a red wave and I believe that we're
going to take back the Congress and
we're going to fire Nancy Pelosi and
that's a good thing I believe JD Vance
is gonna take back
I believe that our Supreme Court
candidates are going to win but none of
that happens unless we do the work in
the military we learned that complacency
is dangerous in fact they tell you that
the most dangerous time in any combat
deployment is those final couple days
people start to think I've got my bags
packed I'm heading home Life's good and
they stop paying attention and that's
when it gets dangerous so we cannot get
uh complacent in these final couple days
we need to be switched on we need to get
our people out to vote and I know that's
what this is all about this is a get out
the vote rally the Republicans are
excited but we need to go out there and
do the work and that's exactly my
message for you now listen we've got a
exactly the right person serving as our
state auditor I served with Keith Faber
in the state senate I can tell you the
man is a watchdog when it comes to
making sure that government efficiency
is maintained and rooting out fraud
waste and abuse he's the guy that
protects your hard-earned taxpayer money
ladies and gentlemen my friend our state
auditor e favorite
foreign
good morning everybody are we having a
good morning
it's great to be here I am your state
auditor I always say it's easy to say
that I don't know how to you I don't
know how to your business and I don't
collect taxes so then somebody like Jim
Hughes is going to say to me what the
heck do you do favor uh and the good
news is what we do in state government
is pretty straightforward we are your
Watchdog over those people who spend
government money and unfortunately since
I've been your state auditor business
has been pretty good we have now
convicted convicted more than 90
individuals for lying stealing and
cheating with your money
Maybe instrumental in identifying what
is now more than five billion dollars of
waste fraud abuse just in the
unemployment compensation system during
the pandemic
that's your money and your kids money
that went to foreign countries or other
places to people who weren't deserving
it but a cause of control weaknesses and
that's what we look for in the state
auditor's office look I love being your
state auditor I'm not going to talk for
a long time about the great things my
office is doing except to say that I am
very very proud of our professional
staff our staff make decisions without
regard to politics without regard to
favor or without regard to anything that
has to do with political decisions they
make those decisions to go after and
wash your money and we have an excellent
staff
and part of the reason part of the
reason that I wanted to point out our
excellent staff is I want to introduce
our attorney general
Dave yose was my predecessor in the
state auditor's office and he left me
what I say is a turnkey state agency he
had made sure that the professionalism
of the state auditor's office was
maintained at such a high level that
when I became state auditor I might be
one of the first state Auditors in State
history that I need to replace anybody
other than filling positions with people
that looked at him at the AG's office we
kept all the staff and that's because he
insisted upon that professionalism that
allowed us to hit the ground running now
we made some changes and did a few
things here differently than they did
but he ran a very professional
organization to stay auditor and he has
taken it to a new level in the Attorney
General's office he has been a great
attorney general he has focused on the
things that keep our communities safe he
has done things to protect us from DCI
and he has continued to go after the bad
guys including just yesterday filing a
lawsuit against somebody who was
charging one price at the sticker at
another price at the register allegedly
it hasn't been convicted yet so alleged
the good news is is that as our attorney
general Dayton has continued
to fight for right so let me introduce
my friend Daniels
[Applause]
and Keith thank you for that kind
introduction and I have to tell you I I
am proud of the staff that we left
behind but Keith's leadership is taking
that to a new level to uh I thought that
we had probably cleaned the place up but
he sound even more corruption that he uh
has brought people to Justice I'm proud
of the work that he's doing there
so my job you might have noticed that
there's some Federal overreach
my job is to go to court try to enforce
the rule law and the Constitutional
norms and I'm proud to do that we've
been going to court fighting for you
fighting for the rule of law and we've
been winning
but I want to urge you that I'm going to
say something and probably know
politician has ever told you
my race
it's not the most important race on the
ballot this year
and so when you leave here and I I see
people that I know volunteer they do
phone Banks
some of you I've seen you go door to
door and let drops
when you leave here and talk
to your friends and family when you do
the volunteer work these last few hours
before election day
I want you to remember the things the
two races that are mattering the most
here the first one is the Supreme Court
because the rule of law means not only
the same rules for everybody
it means that the rules say what they
mean that anybody could read what is
expected
and have a good idea of how to comply
with it
when judges can read things into the
Constitution that aren't there to strike
down statutes they don't like or come to
a particular outcome it doesn't matter
how good your attorney general is it
doesn't matter whether your auditor is
cleaning up local government from
corruption it doesn't matter how clean
your elections are
there is no rule of law at the Supreme
Court doesn't agree that the word say
what the words mean
and so our Sharon and our two cats are
critical to the rule of law and that is
important race number one the second one
I was talking to a friend of mine who
very politically savvy
trying to get him to support me and he
said Dave I love you you're doing a
great job
but the problem facing our country
is not coming out of Columbus Ohio
he didn't know about the Supreme Court
but
he said the problems facing our country
are coming out Washington D.C
and the second most the most important
top-end race that we need to be out
there for these last few days
this is my friend Shady pants because
the future of the Senate
the future of the rule of law the future
of our country
comes down to which party of which
agenda are going to control over the
next two years
I hope that you will go out and fight
these last few days to make sure that JD
Vance and Sharon Kennedy and Pat Fisher
at half the time make it over the Finish
Line together we're in a fight for Ohio
we're going to make Ohio even greater
and we're going to make America
now it's my great question am I honored
to introduce a good friend of mine
and
this is a guy who doesn't need an
introduction but I'm going to do it
anyway because I want to be on public
record that I have immense respect
for John Houston
this man is a competitor he's top
beyond that he has a
organized business mind and the things
that he's done to help lead our state
and economic development to help make
government work more like a business to
be efficient and
oriented toward the ends and not the
process is as good a work as anybody's
doing anywhere in the country right now
will you welcome my friend the
lieutenant governor of Ohio
are we ready to win on Tuesday
[Applause]
all right that's exactly right so uh
it's a pleasure to be with you this
morning we're kicking off this bus tour
we're going to go everywhere in Ohio
have a lot of fun meet a lot of Voters
in preparation for a win on Tuesday but
I want to share with you just quickly
about the difference between where the
Republican party has taken Ohio when the
Democrats have taken the nation
okay look today in Ohio we are creating
jobs faster than we can find people to
fill them you sit here in Franklin
County unemployment rates 3.3
.3 of this 8
. it's great people are going to work
they have opportunity
we have moved the ball forward and we
did it as a republican team this is what
Republicans have done in Ohio
even though we went through a very
difficult
four years
we balance budgets never dipped into the
rainy days
the path
3.6 billion dollars worth of income tax
cuts for every single ohioan
the lowest income tax rates we've had
since the 1970s in our state and we have
the highest Bond rating since the 1970s
Interstate we got our fiscal house in
order
and in Washington trillions and
trillions of death
we also
funded the police in the state
men and women in blue
we value the sacrifice in the service
they have and in our opponent in this
race the defunded the police in Dayton
Ohio
including canceling the police academy
to help train the next generation of
officers
and we also
under Governor dewine's leadership
protected the Border
when Governor Abba called and said hey
we need help down here because the
federal government won't do its job and
we have drugs and human traffickers and
people come across this border he sent
the National Guard he sent the highway
patrol to help protect the Border
we've done the things in this state to
support the Ohio agenda and National
agenda to move our nation forward the
Democrats they've gone in the other
direction
we're staying on the rise
we're a state On The Rise but in
Washington they do things like the
president started out by saying hey
we're gonna we're gonna cancel the
Keystone XL pipeline we're gonna we're
gonna restrict uh Refinery expansions
and then they
achieve their goal of cutting off oil
supplies
gas production in the United States and
then they get inflation they say well
how'd that happen
how'd that happen the inflation that you
experience at the pump and in your back
pocket when you're in the grocery store
is it completely Washington created
problem
completely
and we in Ohio were getting it right
tax cuts focusing on families job trade
putting people to work helping them live
their version of the American dream
right here in Ohio it's happening
[Music]
foreign
you've met many of the members of the
team
uh you're supporting legislators who are
and will be part of that team
of putting all this together
but there always has to be a team
captain
somebody that no matter what you know
you can count on them they're a rock
they've got a vision they stay true to
it and they will work tirelessly to make
sure that it happens and that leader of
this Republican team
and the architect of Ohio's recovery
is not under and Governor Mike dewine
please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
John thank you very very much for all
that you you do we're looking forward to
four more years working together four
more years moving this state forward
four more years of bringing jobs to Ohio
John's been a real leader in doing that
John thank you very very much
we started today
a two day bus trip around the state of
Ohio and we kick it off this morning
thank you all very very much for being
here we're going to be from one end as
as John has said one into the state uh
to the other Fran I just finished a
couple days in Southern Ohio and Eastern
Ohio and I tell you it was a it was a
fun fun trip people very enthusiastic
um this has been an Administration that
has said from the beginning we're
focusing on every single part of the
state of Ohio and I think the people in
Appalachia where we just were get that
they understand that and there was a
great deal of enthusiasm uh there right
before that Fran and I uh were in
Cleveland one of things that we do every
the end of every campaign we try to
stand in front of the warehouse and
Bengals game well of course they were
playing together all you grounds to
answer pretty happy with that
foreign
[Applause]
to close a number of campaigns and I
will tell you this was the best
reception we have ever received
um it was it was not Universal but uh it
was it was a great great reaction and uh
we kind of do our own what we call our
Cleveland Browns uh Bengals bowl and uh
it was it was it was pretty good uh I
want to say something about my bride
here uh Fran has been campaigning and
she achieved something the other day you
were in your 88th County
88th alley she finished she's done every
County
[Applause]
[Music]
she ain't talking about me once in a
while no but what she's really been
doing is promoting the Dolly Parton
Imagination Library and you have some
good news about that you want to share
the news
we're over 50 now state
4 000 kids that are getting the books
every single month
but this is this is our time in Ohio
um this is Ohio's time it really really
is for a number of number of things are
coming together
um we've been able to keep our taxes
down in fact we've lowered our taxes
um when companies look to Ohio they look
at a state where we now have the best
Bond rating we've had since the 1970s
because of the way that we have
conducted things uh it is a state that
is growing jobs we're seeing companies
like like Intel make decisions they
could have picked any state in the Union
they could have gone any place in fact
there was 39 other locations they were
looking at they picked Ohio and they
picked Ohio because of the business
climate the stability in Ohio the hard
workers that we have the colleges the
universities that we have abundance of
water we have in fact we take care of
our water all of those things come
together and also we like to think a
little bit because we were pretty darn
aggressive not only going after Intel
well but going after other companies and
bringing these jobs in here what we know
that we also are doing that is so very
very important and in a second term
we're going to continue to do that
um and we're actually in the process now
of working on on the budget but I said
when I first talked to the state
legislature they've been a great great
partner I said to the legislature look
I'm going to be asking you to invest in
people
I'm going to ask you to invest in the
people of the state of Ohio and I'm
going to ask you to invest sometimes in
things work we're not going to see the
results overnight in fact in some cases
we will not really see the results until
all of us are out of office and that is
a tough tough thing for people to do but
the legislature has done it we've
invested for example in in Lake Erie a
long-term project to make sure that not
only Lake Erie but our other waters
around the state are in good condition
we call it H2 Ohio and it's interesting
when when we were talking to Intel on
things they mentioned is we like what
you're doing uh in regard to what you
call H2 Ohio but that long-term
investment and there's nothing more
important than long-term investment in
reaching children early so Dolly Parton
imagination libraries just is one
example of that but we we've doubled the
emphasis and the money and the resources
that we put in prenatal care postnatal
care visiting
family visitings and help her families
to get a good start we want kids to get
to kindergarten and to be there and
ready ready to go but it's not just that
it is what happens after that Fred and I
and John I know spend a lot of time
doing it as well have traveled around
the state going to our Career Centers
we've invested more in our career since
we've invested more in our community
colleges and in the second term you're
going to see that continue again why
because we want every single child to be
able to live up to their god-given
potential we want every ohioan to have
the opportunity to live whatever their
version of the American dream is
not it's not just our young people
a program that John
wanted us to start and we did called
Tech Red where we basically tell
companies if you got an employee and he
or she needs to have their skills up
taken up and it's an industry recognized
credential guess what we'll pay for it
and now we've had John what over 50
Ohioans
it is so exciting to go into Career
Centers and to go and talk to these
young people and they tell you
what they're excited about and some of
them tell us look I wasn't too excited
about school before we're doing
something I love
and I I know how much money I'm gonna
make and I'm I just love it and when you
talk to those kids uh it just makes you
you feel good and also tells you this is
where Ohio's future is we're investing
in these kids we're investing in young
people we're investing in our workers uh
and it's going to make a huge huge
difference look we're moving in Ohio
this truly for many many reasons is is
our time our time in history
where we're not going in the right
direction I think is pretty clear and
that is in Washington D.C but we have a
candidate we have a candidate 396 Senate
who is going to take Ohio our messages
and the people of Ohio and what we care
about to Washington DC this is someone
who's a conservative who's going to be a
strong Ohio voice in Washington D.C we
need him JD Vance I've known for a
number of years he brings a a unique
background
to this position
he's someone who will be our advocate
and look we don't know how these other
races are going to turn out around the
country we only can deal with one
we only have Impacto one but we have an
obligation because
this
seat in Ohio
May determine which party controls
United States Senate
I had the opportunity
to serve with in the house and then the
Senate with Chuck Schumer uh look the
choices is pretty clear
this man may decide who the next
Majority Leader is
your vote may decide who the next
Majority Leader is let me just tell you
from my experiences that it matters who
the majority leader is it matters who
the majority party is so
let's keep pushing let's keep pushing
the next five days six days as we go
down I I believe in fighting right right
to the polls close at 7 30 at night and
I know you all do as well I've seen many
of you out there seen many of you work
at the polls uh thank you for what
you're doing let's continue to push up
the Supreme Court is vitally important
finally important for all the reasons
that you've already heard let's now
introduce the next United States senator
from Ohio
okay
thank
you
thank you all so much governor and Fran
thank you for for being here thanks for
coming out on the campaign Trail and and
everybody else uh Frank Dave John the
entire team
um Keith and and uh and Robert we really
appreciate having you guys out here and
of course our important Supreme Court
Justices uh Sharon and the two packs
we've got to get Sharon in the two pass
it sounds like a rock group
maybe an R B group actually uh but we
got to get them across the finish line
and so it's great to be out here with
all of you and it's great to have your
support we're going to win on November
8th ladies
[Music]
foreign
who passed away recently and he went up
to uh the Pearly Gates and he was he was
talking with Saint Peter and Saint Peter
said would you like to go to heaven or
would you like to go to hell and the guy
said well honestly I've never been to
either place can I check him out and so
St Peter said sure why not and so they
hop on the elevator they go down they
check out hell and the guy's you know
pretty surprised by it there's loud
music people are partying and having a
good time it's a really fun place he
says you know this is not at all I was
led to to believe uh can I go check out
heaven so they hop back on the elevator
they go up and Heaven's a beautiful
place filled with very friendly people
but the guy who looks at St Peter and
says you know this is this is pretty
unconventional but I actually think that
I prefer to go to hell and St Peter says
look man that's your choice so they hop
back down in the elevator they go down
down the door opens it's hot it's smelly
people are complaining and bothered and
the guy sees the devil over the corner
and he says hey man what's going on this
is not at all what I was led to expect
and the devil says well uh when you were
down here a couple hours ago I was out
of the campaign Trail
the the
new told me that joke was Ursula Walker
um so so I I think about that a lot but
look look we we've got such a such a
great slate of candidates and let me
tell you just a little bit about myself
I was raised uh by my working class
grandparents my memo and Papaw and a lot
of you know my story and a lot of you
probably don't and so you know my story
is really the story of the American
dream and the story of what happens when
our state and when our country works for
our young people you heard the governor
talk about giving every kid an
opportunity in the state of Ohio and
that's ultimately what we're trying to
do I was raised by a woman who didn't go
to high school she was an unusual woman
in a lot of ways she was a woman of very
very deep Christian faith even though
she hadn't graduated from high school
she was the most thoughtful Christian
that I ever met she also really loved
the f word so there was sort of a
contrast yeah memo hadn't had both
things going on at the exact same time
but that discipline and that love and
that dedication is what was necessary
for me to be able to to live my dreams
and to have a good chance and you know
when I was a kid all I really wanted to
do was be a good husband and a good
father I wanted to be able to give my
kids the things that I didn't have and
that's the way in which the state of
Ohio that's the way in which this
country has been so good to me is it's
given me the opportunity to provide for
my family in a way that we maybe didn't
have when I was growing up in a working
class family in Middletown Ohio and
that's what we want and that's what
we're fighting for for every single
child in the state of Ohio and that's
what is on the ballot on November the
8th and let's let's just talk about you
know what's going on in the state of
Ohio versus what's going on in
Washington and why it's so important for
us to win this race and why it's so
important for us to protect the American
dream to the Next Generation for our
kids and our grandkids think about what
our grandparents and our
great-grandparents gave us and think
about what we risk squandering unless we
get better leadership in Washington DC
you just heard the governor talk about
how much the Intel facility means to the
state of Ohio and it's not really just
the state of Ohio the Intel facility
represents us making a smart decision
where for 30 years we have shipped our
manufacturing and Industrial base off to
China that facility represents bringing
it right back home where it belongs
using Ohio Workers to make the things
that we need all across the country as
National Security implications you don't
want the Chinese making the computer
chips that our troops May rely on in
their tanks and their missiles uh in
their jet engines but that's what's
going on right now and that's why we
have to bring these facilities back back
home to Ohio and back home to America
but here's the thing
but here's the thing about about that
you can't manufacture computer chips or
anything else unless you have high
quality energy low cost energy and
ladies and gentlemen we've got plenty of
it right here in the state of Ohio we've
got plenty of it here right here in the
United States of America and yet we have
a president who goes to every 10-pot
dictator in the world and begs for
energy when we've got plenty of it here
in our own home let's get it out of the
ground and refine it with Ohio Workers
in Ohioans
[Music]
foreign
Governor talk about the importance of
technical education I happen to believe
that you should be able to live the
American dream whether you go to college
or not we need Pathways to the middle
class for everybody whatever your
educational background is and and and
and the governor lieutenant governor
deserve a lot of credit for that but
still right now in Washington we spend
so much more money on the traditional
four-year degree program and so little
money on the technical colleges that are
preparing people for the skills of
tomorrow and the jobs of tomorrow that
needs to stop if we want to invest in
technical education we need the federal
government to do a better job and that's
exactly what we're going to do in the
United States Senate now here's and
here's here's the worst of all it's not
just about investing in the future it's
not just about being proactive we need
to do that and I appreciate what the
governor said that you need to make
investments where you won't see the
return for 10 or 20 years that's how you
govern a country effectively that's a
government state effectively but we've
also got to be reactive to some of the
bad things coming out of Washington DC
this inflation crisis is directly caused
by The Reckless spending and the
terrible energy policies of Joe Biden
and Tim Ryan okay we know it we know
what happens when you go to war against
your own energy sector you put a lot of
your workers out of job and you raise
prices for everybody else that is a
disaster ladies and gentlemen and the
middle class is paying the price
remember when Joe Biden ran for
president he said he wouldn't raise
taxes on